hi I'm Lori NT and you're watching  another GS news update the cost of  subscribing to blizzards MMORPG world of  warcraft will increase for the UK this  november lizard has announced an  increase of the recommended retail  pricing for subscription period a 30-day  sub will cost 99 pounds 90 days will  cross 2817 pounds and 180 days will cost  50 214 pounds the 60-day prepaid time  card will increase to 2099 this marks  increases of up to six pounds when the  changes hit in November was it also  stated that world of warcraft  subscribers who are currently on a  recurring subscription will be able to  retain their prices for two years as  long as the period is not interrupted  this will extend to players who sign up  for recurring subscriptions for four  walls of Draenor is released what do you  think will the price changes impact the  number of occurring subscribers on World  of Warcraft let us know in the comments  below